حرب ممنهجة،
هي ليست حوادث عرضية مستجدة،
تهجير وقتل واضطهاد وانتهاكات،
يتعرض المسلمون في الهند لأبشع أنواع العنف والتعذيب،
جنود يقتلون شابا مسلما،
وصحفي ينكل بجثته،
يوما بعد يوم تزداد حدة الانتهاكات الدامية،
التي سقط ويسقط بسببها آلاف القتلى،
فأين العالم الإسلامي؟ وأين هم ملوك  الخليج
الذين يمتلكون أكبر عمالة هندية؟
وأين منظمات حقوق الإنسان؟..
انقسامات طائفية وتقسيم عرقي، حرب طائفية دينية جائرة،
فما الذي يحدث لمسلمي الهند في الوقت الراهن؟
في الهند ظل الشعب والحكومة متعايشين فيما بينهم،
من كل الأطياف والطوائف،
حتى انتهى حكم حزب غاندي رجل التعايش،
وجاء للسلطة الحزب اليميني الأكثر تطرفا،
انقلبت حياة المسلمين هناك رأسا على عقب،
فعلى الرغم أن عدد المسلمين يصل لقرابة ٢٠٠مليون نسمة،
إلا أنه يتم اضطهادهم بشكل مروع من قبل السلطات والهندوس،
فالسلطات الهندية مؤخرا تشن حملة تهجير
لمئات العائلات المسلمة من دولبور في سيباجار بمقاطعة آسام شمال شرقي البلاد.
في حملة الإخلاء هذه ، أعمال عنف وتعسف
في تعامل الشرطة مع المدنيين  تتسبب بقتل المدنيين العزّل،
وإصابة الكثير منهم.
فهنا يظهر مدني رافضا للإخلاء يشتبك مع أفراد من الشرطة
فيطرحوه أرضا وسط إطلاق وابل من الرصاص
ثم ينزلون على جسده بالهراوات....
لم تكتمل القصة بعد فيقفز صحفي على جثة الشاب
وينهال عليه ضربا وينكل بجثته،
ياااالها من قسوة،
وهل صارت الصحافة المسالمة في العالم هكذا!!!!
( وهذه ليست إلا قصة لجريمة بسيطة مقارنة
بالقتل الجماعي والإبادة التي يتعرض لها المسلمون هناك)
السلطات الهندية تُهجّر  بشكل تعسفي وقسري
أكثر من 800 عائلة مسلمة في ولاية آسام،
وتزيل مساكنهم البسيطة المصنوعة من الصفيح،
وذلك بحجة أنها مقامة على أرض مملوكة للدولة....
والشرطة في المنطقة تواجه الحزام البشري المحتج بالنار،
ليسقط جراء الاشتباكات عدد من القتلى والمصابين..
بالعودة إلى الوراء قليلا .. فقد سيطر المسلمون على معظم أجزاء المنطقة
ودخل الهندوس في الإسلام أفواجاً أفواجاً حتى شكلوا أقلية مسلمة،
فأصبحوا مجموعة كبيرة ضمت حوالي ثلث سكان شبه القارة الهندية
قبيل استقلال المنطقة عن بريطانيا. لكن مع دخول الإسلام للهند
شعر الكثير من الهندوس بالسوء، ...
ازداد الأمر سوءا بتدمير الهندوس لمسجد بابري لقيموا معبدا لهم بعد ذلك،..
ومنذ مجيئ رئيس الوزراء الهندي ناريندرا مودي ٢٠١٤،
فقد وضع المسلمون أيديهم على قلوبهم خوفا مما سيحدث لهم،
لمعرفتهم لماضي مودي السيء وكرهه للمسلمين،
بدأت الانتقادات توجه إلى مودي قبل وصولة لرئاسة الحكومة بعام واحد،
بسبب قتل المئات من المسلمين في ولايته، لكنه زاد الطين بلة
وأثار غضب العالم عليه عندما شبه ضحايا المسلمين
(بالجراء التي تدهسها السيارات)..
أي وقاحة هذه،!!!،،،
مودي أصدر قانونا بتحويل الهند إلى وطن للهندوس،
ومنع الهجرة إلى الهند من الدول الجارة لها،
إلا لأصحاب الديانات الهندوسية والمسيحية والسيخية...
وصلت الإعتداءات أشدها مؤخرا،، فاندلعت أعمال عنف طائفية
سقط ضحيتها عشرات القتلى والجرحى من المسلمين،
وأحرقت ودمرت ممتلكات كثيرين،  وعندما حاولت النساء المسلمات
أن يهربن بأطفالهن بعد أن أشعلت الحرائق في منازل عوائلهن ومتاجر أزوجهن
،، مزقوا ملابسهن أمام أطفالهن،،
بل وصل الحال بأحد المعتدين الهندوس أن خلع ملابس طفل ليتأكد هل هو مختون،
لأن الختان عادة أسلامية لا يطبقها الهندوس،،، ماااا هذه البشاعة والقسوة!!!!
وهنا طفل يتمسك بجثة والده، الذي قتله الهندوس فقط لأنه مسلم،..
ما ذنب هذا الطفل، ليرى أباه جثة هامدة أمام ناظريه..
الهندوس لم يتركوا المسلمين وشأنهم، حتى أنهم أصبحوا يقمعون الصحفيين للتأكد إن كانوا مسلمين،،
فهذا مصور حاصروه في منطقة أثناء تغطيته الاحتجاجات، ليضايقوه عبر الضغط عليه للكشف عما إذا كان مسلما أم هندوسيا.
وذاك مراسل تلفزيوني تعرّض للضرب من قبل مجموعة هندوسية
أثناء تصويرهم بهاتفه وهم يهدمون حائط مقبرة للمسلمين.
الشرطة الهندية تخل بمبادئها وقوانينها بشكل فاضح وواضح،
فما هو رد المسلمين والخليج العربي خصوصا؟...
(ردة الفعل العربية)
مع تصاعد استهداف الهندوس للمسلمين في الهند،
جاءت الردود على استحياء من العرب والمسلمين،
فالمملكة العربية السعودية والإمارات خصوصا،
يمتلكان عمالة كبيرة للهند، إذ يتوجب عليهم على الأقل أن يهددوا بقطع العمالة الهندية،
فتسريح العمالة الهندية سيكون كارثة للهند وقرارا رادعا
وتهديدا للحكومة الهندية، لوقف التعسف ضد المسلمين،،
ويأتي تنديد مجلس الأمة الكويتي بالاعتداءات التي يتعرض لها مسلمو الهند،
ليعلنوا تضامنهم مع المسلمين هناك، واستنكروا الأمر رسميا،
لكن بدون تهديد بقطع العلاقات أو إنشاء أي ضغوط على الحكومة الهندية،
ومن العاصمة القطرية الدوحة أصدر "الاتحاد العالمي لعلماء المسلمين"
بياناً؛ يستنكر ما يتعرض له مسلمو الهند،
وناشد الاتحاد العالمي "العالم أجمع، التعاون البنّاء الحقيقي الصادق
لتحقيق السلم والسلام الاجتماعي على مستوى جميع الدول وبموازين دقيقة واحدة..
يعيش في الهند نحو مائتي مليون مسلم، يمثلون نحو ،14،9% من السكان،
ما يجعلها أكبر دولة تضم أقلية مسلمة في العالم.
ورغم أن المسلمين هناك أقلية، فهم بهذا العدد الضخم
يفوقون الكثير من الدول الإسلامية عددا،
لكن أين المناصرون؟ وأين من يدعون نصرة المسلمين في كل بقاع الأرض؟
..